TikTok is a mobile-first platform for creating and sharing short videos.
Most tend to be about 15 seconds long though the app does allow videos up to 60 seconds in length.
The platform's story began in September 2016, when its Beijing-based parent company, ByteDance...
...launched the app in China under the name, "Douyin."
About a year later, ByteDance released the app internationally,...
...but with new branding and a new name, TikTok, though it still goes by Douyin at home.
In 2018, ByteDance acquired Musical.ly for a reported one billion dollars.
Despite being headquartered in Shanghai, the app, mostly used for lip-syncing,...
...was popular with American teenagers.
Musical.ly users were eventually migrated to TikTok,...
...and now the app boasts more monthly active users than Twitter, Snapchat or LinkedIn,...
...though it still has a way to go before catching up to Facebook, YouTube and Instagram.
ByteDance, which owns several other apps too, is now valued at 75 billion dollars,...
...making it the most valuable start-up on the planet.